it's a nice morning out there a little
chilly so don't forget the coats the
jackets for sure early light but no
sunlight yet it's just a little bit of
that civil twilight mother nature hasn't
turned on the full
sun floodlight yet beautiful shot though
looking out towards the mountains where
we've had some breezes up there at kyle
canyon they're calm down a little bit 33
at red rock cold morning out there for a
bike ride or hike this morning 38
sunrise mountain 36 in nellis got some
30's mainly around the fringes the
interior of the valley in the low 40s
this morning outside the valley cold 20s
up in indian springs this morning
caliente at 22. ely's actually gone up
to 18 degrees in the last hour 34 in
perum we've got mid-50s in loughlin
where those north winds are still
blowing at times over 30 miles an hour
so every once in a while generates
pretty good wind gusts there 30 in
kingman and 36 in mesquite the moapa
valley mainly in the mid 30s so here are
your headlines increasing clouds
tomorrow got a couple of systems one
from the south one from the north clouds
coming in from the one off the southern
baja coast tomorrow and then breezy
winds come in on friday that's from a
system pushing through the northwest and
the rockies will be slightly cooler but
mostly sunny for your weekend still
looks pretty good so here's the one up
north more showers some snow showers for
the northwest and the rockies we're kind
of protected by high pressure right now
from nevada over to the four corners and
then this is the system off the coast of
baja california and it is slowly
starting to lift to the north and that
will lead to the increase in clouds
later today into tonight
and tomorrow so by tonight we'll be at
least partly cloudy and then thursday
we'll have mostly cloudy skies so today
enjoy the beautiful sunshine get that
good vitamin d soak it all up it really
is healthy for you helps boost your
immune system and of course you should
be eating citrus fruits and getting lots
of sleep and that'll help guard you
against the cold and flu season and
covet of course that's going around
tomorrow cloudy skies and then mid to
upper 60s friday with those breezy winds
behind that system slightly cooler but
really nice through mlk weekend and for
the parade on monday morning next week
we stay in the 60s very mild that means
the morning's kind of mild too